Obstruction is very quickly becoming the name
of the game because Donald Trump is now officially
retired
using to cooperate with the house's impeachment
inquiry.
We will talk about what this means.
We will talk about what will happen next,
which is really the most important question.
I told you before that there are just too
many differences between bill Clinton's impeachment
and Donald Trump's impeachment to really draw
relevant parallels in terms of the course
that they might take, the outcome that they
might have.
A bill Clinton's impeachment was overlying
about an affair.
Donald Trump's is over borderline treasonous
behavior.
Clinton wasn't tweeting all day about it.
Donald Trump is, Clinton didn't have something
equivalent to Fox news and right wing radio
and the social media echo chambers that Donald
Trump has.
Clinton cooperated with the inquiry while
Trump was always likely not to, and now we
know that he will not.
The white house said yesterday it will not
cooperate with this impeachment inquiry period.
They said this in a letter of eight or nine
pages of length where he calls the entire
thing unconstitutional despite of course impeachment
being enshrined in the founding documents.
Of the United States of America.
Uh, the letter is filled with complete non
arguments about why he will not be participating
and this is now going to set up a major battle
with Democrats in the house.
This is like telling the police, no, you are
not allowed to investigate me.
I don't participate.
And I think you investigating my possible
crimes is harassment at the highest level.
If you did that, the police through the courts
would enforce their right to investigate.
And the question now is, will the house in
force, it's right to investigate, but it's
actually more simply will they, will the subpoenas
even start if the subpoenas start, will the
subpoenas be enforced?
Because you can subpoena anybody you want.
And a court can even say, you must abide by
the subpoena, Mr. Trump, mr Trump's lawyer,
whoever.
But what if you just ignore that court decision?
What if you ignore that court's decree?
So far there have been no consequences to
Donald Trump or others that he's directed
to ignore requests and subpoenas.
And unless that changes, Trump's going to
get away with this.
This is actually, you know we, we were told
about there could be a constitutional crisis.
This is actually a constitutional crisis.
You need to understand that it's not a hypothetical
one.
It is one right now there is no legal basis
for Donald Trump's position that a coequal
branch of government using its investigative
power is unconstitutional.
There is no legal basis for ignoring requests
from such a constitutional inquiry.
You can make the argument that Trump not cooperating
in and of itself is actually an impeachable
act.
You could make the argument that the specifics
of the Ukraine fiasco that are being adjudicated
presumably by the impeachment inquiry becomes
secondary to what is clearly the impeachable
action of not cooperating with a legal constitutional
inquiry conducted by the power vested in a
coequal branch of government.
And do you know why Trump and his lawyers
are doing this?
I mean you need only look at the last two
and a half years.
It's worked so far, they suspect, and they're
not crazy to suspect it, that based on how
things have gone the last two years, that
ultimately they will not be forced to participate
or to face consequences rather if they are
told to participate but decided not to anyway.
So why not try this?
My my senses and in reading a lot of legal
opinion about this over the last couple of
days, my sense is that even if Trump doesn't
get the gravity of the situation that he's
facing here, that his attorneys do get it.
And so they have made a strategic decision
that Hey, just not going along with this stuff
has served us pretty well.
We got Trump out of having to meet with Mueller
in person and instead he answered questions
in writing.
Bogus answers.
I mean deceptive answers, incomplete answers,
answers that by any normal assessment we would
say are untruths in many ways.
And he got away with it.
So this is obviously the right decision that
one would make if so far they've gotten away
with just not participate in getting in the
way, not doing the thing.
So we've got a constitutional crisis here.
We will soon see whether it will be resolved
in accordance with the constitution and we
will.
I mean, listen, the most important thing at
this point is going to be are Democrats going
to get it together and do everything that
they can to force compliance with this investigation?
Trump may still ignore it.
Trump may still not participate, but Democrats
need to start using their subpoena power.
They need to start looking at holding people
in contempt.
There is a mechanism for doing this.
We've not even really discussed it because
it seems so remote.
The idea is so remote to me that we would
actually see contempt.
People held in contempt by their refusal to
participate, but this is the conversation
we're having.
It is a constitutional crisis right now, not
at some point in the future.
Let me know on Twitter or in the YouTube comments,
please tell me what you think the end result
will be of Donald Trump saying we are simply
not going to participate